and that's athleticism that's quickness
that's competitiveness all in a nutshell
with a pad stop on Thomas who still has
a chance back door vavich robbed by The
Outlaw and that's athleticism that's
quickness that's competitiveness all
in a nutshell what a stop with the blocker
side the others come in what a terrific save
from D ladar absolutely robing C round my
oh my what a save by Dan Vadar here just
stay in the hunt for that puck extends the arm
catches it off the shoulder that was label top
shelf steals it away side of the net oh want to
stop Ingram robbing ell Conor Ingram laying out
unbelievable yeah he is standing on his pumpkin
right now Conor Ingram and look at the M off
the glove off the bucket and out kachuck
with a long shot save Guston rebound and
a sliding save by gustofson an unbelievable
glove stop by the Minnesota golender what a
super save that was what a save there's
the rebound look at that juicy rebound
there in front to Stone Dam Rob byin Andy
scramble in front play is stopped Stone
Doria there's the left pad the followup
hits the back of his other pad and then
there's Stone in front no lights inches
away of adding to the lead but can't get
it done great chances real late sturing a
couple of big stops Miller batted it out of
there CHS out in front baling in the feed and
Anthony stolar is an incredible save on cof
well we'll look back if the Panthers come back
and win this game or at least get a point you'll
see it a save like this back and forth sent the
that knock down rebound what a save by stolar
he was down and he reached back with the glove
to preserve the lead and stolar just laid out
and reached with that glove hand and just took a
sure goal away that one will be on the Highlight
Reel here's Raymond again back across oh what
a save by vasileski an excellent save on that
one timer from David pan and how baseli he had
to read this Play What a save by bassi is Right
drift to the puck here's a big chance oh what
a stop by vosi are you kidding me unbelievable
save what a stop by Andre vasileski you won't
see him much better than that from one of the
greatest golender in the game for panan to box a
shot save rebound save his rck rck got the rebound
chance and it goes off the side of the skate of
rck and then he kicks it out right there ho nail
save rker Evans the shot rebound oh sov with
his best to hold that out on a rebound chance
and a sensational save by samsonov who gets
congratulations and here comes Tatar McAn walking
in back to Tatar SP extion two pad stops down and
seemingly Out close call here of one save another
save and a third for Samson off MCC across what
a save my goodness what a stop by Elia samsonoff
oh samsonoff a 10 Beller unbelievable
stop to keep it a one-goal lead for the
Leafs here's a fe de my oh my what a save
by Wedgewood and the rebounds kept out Scott
Wedgewood full extension keeps the Stars ahead
he got a chunk of it but he was flat Frozen it's
like ah please somebody help it was about a
foot from the goal line and for spins away
from Hughes gets to his backand vit comes all
the way out of the blue paint and makes the
save he gets as big as he possibly can right here
and he challenges out towards the puck that puck
just barely stayed on that Skate St the only man
back though that set a m alone deep Stone by cor
pasalo last line of defense was cor pasalo and
he rocks mat what a great right Pat a but they
show the strength and the flexibility by Corpus
Salo he had missed 21 for the steal here laier
is D turned it over and Thompson sprawling to
keep it out tro had a chance as well in tight
fast start for the Rangers putting pressure on
Alexi laier tried to stuff it in denied by Logan
Thompson by stroll he a pass across and what a
save by bton Auto vkin is best Save Tonight on
the great eight what a save there my gosh so
vkin that's his spot one times it nonetheless
Jordan Bennington split pad save keep the puck
out here they come again bar declair what a save
by Gibson and then the rebound pushed Underneath
Him Great Stop on Anthony duclair brilliant save
by Gibson who just got enough of it with the heel
of the catching hand bouncing back to zo turns it
over to Suzuki senters a KCK out oh what a
stop by corello and Coffield wow I thought
that was a labeled goal after the turnover by
ardam Zu and coroso with his best save in the
game that aerial centering pass right up the gut
broin glov save keer dazzling that is dazzling
indeed buddy what a stop and Darcy keer saves
the Caps bacon on a break down in front of their
net